ma ciao bel bambino che vampiro
spaventoso che sai che paura che tu te
l'ho detto non mi piacciono gli horror
non mi fanno paura fine senti questo ti
farà paura fidati e bellissimo te l'ho
detto non mi piacciono gli horror non mi
fanno paura basta fidati questo ti farà
paura o dici sempre dalla sigla urlerà i
te lo giuro guarda ciao ragazzi per
piano
no credo abbiamo la stessa maschera lo
sapevo dopo che si mina magnetica e pina
login
ciao no abbiamo la stessa mascherati
nuovo ma fa però cosa ti dico chiari
preferisco a quelle di tessuti disegnini
perché perché sono impegnative e si
avviano poco non è vero che c'è tremonti
non ci pensi che tante grazie volentieri
ciao mamma priva della festa di
halloween
ciao ciao tesoro halloween che cosa è
questa
halloween la festa delle zucche ho
capito vito via manno perché ti sei
vestita così ma tra poco inizia la festa
digitale di halloween vanno organizzati
dei compagni digitale allawi che cos'è
questa halloween halloween
vediamo in questa immensa idiozia questa
immensa stupida americanata che abbiamo
importato anche nel nostro paese
ecco halloween è il monumento alla
imbecillità cosa impazzito guarda è lo
dicono anche internet è un monumento
all'imbecillità tu adesso di cambi altro
calda wind non lo fa è halloween e lo è
lo indovino da sola sono vestita fermare
facile malefica sono sapevo che era un
po scontato questo vestito e noi ci
siamo tutti stasera abbiamo joker
abbiamo la sposa cadavere poi c'è cioè
morticia e mari una cosa devi fare
cioè halloween dovi travestirti ma io
sono travestita sentiamo la cosa da
quarantena da facciamo i bambini e
dolcetto scherzetto
ovviamente dolcetto aspettiamo troppo
[Musica]
ciao dei bambini
certo scherzetto dolce e allora io
innanzitutto vi regalo due mascherine è
così perché la salute prima di tutto per
poco ci sono le caramelle avete
igienizzato le mani no allora facciamo
che io me le lance vuole prendere al
volo ok c'è il vetro di distanza
[Musica]